another story that's probably more
important to our politics
now that we move past the hollywood and
the punching um stories um the supreme
court has upheld the differential
treatment of residents of puerto rico
ruling that congress has within its
power to exclude them from a benefits
program that's available in all 50
states in the district of columbia um
puerto rico really gets [ __ ] on um by
this country a lot of people don't even
know that puerto rico's
puerto ricans are americans like they
have no clue um you know and it's
because of [ __ ] like this
this decision i think is like a nine one
decision so this is an eight one
decision what's it eight yeah what are
you what are you what are you uh
expanding the chord here i i would like
i would
is reasonable but but um um
them upholding and and i think probably
uh even the liberal justices who upheld
this and made this decision it's because
they're signaling hey the only way
really to to do away with some of these
problems with some of our territories is
to make these territories actual states
and give them statehood and give these
people actual citizenship um you know
it is it is sad that there are americans
out there that aren't considered
americans not just not just by default
but by [ __ ] legal legal means right
like these people cannot access social
security income they cannot access the
ssi
um and i think that's the main decision
here or the program the main program
that was before the court was the ssi i
believe
is the uh was the you know puerto rico
is the place if you want to go help
during a you know a uh
natural disaster just toss them some
paper towels well donald trump didn't
even know puerto rico was america i
don't i actually don't believe he
actually he actually thought yeah they
had to tell him that and like he did not
know that until they told and he owned
[ __ ] property there
right i mean there's a ton right like
people you know suzanne brings up a good
point right guam another great place i
got a good buddy who's from guam
uh good food good people mm-hmm um but
it's enough it's a really important
territory to our national security as
well exactly it's not just it's it's not
just great people and the reason why we
have guam is because it's so vital to
our national security right and and
that's why
it's there yeah that's why the
it's still one of our territories is
because we see it as a vital uh asset to
our national security right so so it it
like i haven't i haven't read
like the actual kind of case notes on
this one my assumption and i could be
very wrong here my assumption is that
because we're not willing to grant them
the statehood that they deserve they
they rightfully deserve statehood and
those benefits it's saying like well if
they're not a state
then should they get the benefits and
that's what i feel like is being argued
here as opposed to if it is a state and
obviously it's not within the
continental like you know actual united
states you know the the lower 48 in
alaska
um
that they shouldn't even get it right
that includes dc puerto rico guam
whatever like i feel like these areas
should most definitely however because
republicans don't want to
give a
uh diverse group of people
uh the rights of a statehood because
obviously they would probably vote
not in their favor to to republicans
that they want to look at this and say
well they're not a state so they don't
get rights like it's it's like the
assumption that oh well they're like a
they're like a cousin should i really
invite them to the wedding to like
hang out in the reception you know like
that's what i feel like the treatment is
here well but you know this is this is
the same
thing of of legislating like roe v wade
right like codifying they should codify
something that even even if it's not
statehood that they give right that they
still extend the equal and equitable
rights that all other americans get
under under our constitution they can
possibly surely they can pass
legislation i think that's probably in
the decision if you read the decision
from some of the liberal justices that's
probably what they're saying is hey look
you have to do this with legislation you
have to codify these people to actually
receive these benefits in the
constitution like we have to get
something a piece of legislation passed
that shows this because the the past
decisions don't give bearing to the idea
that that folks and territories even
though they are american citizens right
they're not full american citizens which
is ridiculous everyone everyone should
have equality and equity i don't care
what territory you come from actually
honestly i think you should have a
quality equity even if you're not a
legal citizen a legal uh migrant in this
country [ __ ] that [ __ ] you're a human
being we should give you show you some
goddamn humanity but it it really is
pathetic that we
we have to do this whole rudy georgiany
thing yeah um it's really [ __ ] gross
i mean it's a good like there was a i
think somebody brought this up when it
came to the will smith oscar moment
right like the slap happened that video
got shared what it went oh yeah no yeah
we totally masked over what was going on
in ukraine in russia and people were
like we can't even get the attention
that we deserve like we had attention
then we lost it for a week and then we
got it back on and even then after that
i like really wasn't like 100 you know
uh i don't see it as much as my feed and
stuff i mean i catch here and there but
you know it's also i mean i will admit
it's very hard to keep up with a new
cycle because things move so quickly and
there's always like you know small
spurts of stuff here and there and
you're like wait what you know and
you're trying to focus on you know what
lies ahead
um but it's another thing like as an
example you said 6.9 million views and
you're like this is what people care
about which is yes unfortunate that we
had an insurrectionist just try to try
to rebrand himself
right as the yucky old grandpa because
there's another clip i'm not going to
show it but there's another clip where
nick cannon is asking him why he came on
the show and he's like oh my grandkids
and blah blah blah and i want to be a i
want to be a hip grandpa or some
[ __ ] um here let me let me show you
what gabe's talking about here with the
news and
some of the uh the trends here mike
tyson's uh trending here let me zoom in
here if i can make it work mike tyson is
still trending number one which you know
that's cool and we talked about it but
mike tyson shouldn't be trending number
one chris wallace is trending number two
which that shouldn't be a thing cnn plus
is number three quibby
which is another streaming service that
doesn't [ __ ] exist anymore right
it's trending number four because cnn
plus is right um
of course uh an actor dying there
but i mean as far as news articles
here's the amber herd is trending number
10
um and all the way down to number 12
is puerto ricans not receiving their
equal and equitable rights as americans
like literally this i i'm not saying you
couldn't even make the top ten right
right i'm not saying like you know how
you know how important this was scroll
up
uh
one
go up scroll no sorry scroll up the
number 11
boom light year which i'm not gonna oh
hey look at look at look i'm a big toy
story fan but the fact that lightyear is
trending above uh above a place that
should have benefits and statehood
rights like every other american citizen
does
is crazy right like i know i know well i
mean and this just shows you our
discourse um of what's important and i
was i was ranting about this um earlier
um about how we have to get our
messaging straight and the generic
ballot is not gonna pay attention to
this
they're not going to have any [ __ ]
clue you think the average american out
there is going to hear that the supreme
court basically told puerto ricans to go
[ __ ] themselves you're not american i
mean you're kinda you're kind of
american citizens right
most of those people who won't know
about this story don't even know puerto
rico is an american territory
and that's the problem that we have is
that people aren't [ __ ] engaged
in political discourse and engaged in
our civics of our country the [ __ ]
that's actually important the [ __ ] that
gives you light year the [ __ ] that gives
you um
johnny depp and amber heard being actors
in hollywood the [ __ ] that delivers you
i don't know things like quibby and cnn
plus and chris wallace even considering
being on a streaming platform and the
ability for mike tyson to even get on an
airplane right that kind of [ __ ]
that kind of [ __ ] relies on liberty like
all that [ __ ] relies on liberty yeah and
and here we have a a [ __ ] story
about american citizens not getting
their full liberty
in equality and equity
granted to them by the constitution
because the supreme court says no really
the constitution does not grant people
in territories
constitutional rights right that other
people have in this country
[ __ ] crit and here it is number 12.
number [ __ ] 12.
it's absolutely bonkers batshit crazy
and then look we can even go down the
list even further snack wraps is number
16.
bring back snack wraps
the mcrib right and here we are number
20
the story of of the leader of the house
minority and during the erection just
three hours ago this story dropped right
kevin mccarthy and mitch mcconnell i
mean it's not a surprise that they're
[ __ ] counting i already knew this
right but but it's being reported by the
new york times of quotes that they said
this is
they wanted to overthrow our
constitution they wanted to overthrow
your way of life
the way of life that affords you the
light year affords you to the ability to
[ __ ] about amber heard and johnny depp
being in court over punching each other
in the face and hitting each other with
vodkas and [ __ ] in each other's beds
and and having a good laugh about the
wills will smith and mike tyson moments
could you think you think that that a
bunch of fascists would will smith or
mike tyson have riches get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ]
come on get get real get real and
number number 20 is a story about how
the republican party in this country
wanted to overthrow the constitution in
the united states
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
that that's that's where we're at that's
where we're at folks and we gotta
recognize that that's where we're at
like if we don't get with that truth and
understand the truth of where our
political discourse is in this country
and understand why donald trump got
elected folks this is why
this is why this trending list this
morning is the reason why donald trump
got elected it's because this country
gives a [ __ ] more about reality
television than they give a [ __ ] about
who the vice president is
who they care if the secretary of
state's doing their [ __ ] job
rather they rather who the department of
homeland security's director is they
don't give a [ __ ] rather they care how
much money greg abbott is costing the
american people because he's checking
the pressure and tires of produce trucks
to make sure that produce doesn't get on
grocery store shelves
intentionally he's trying to ruin your
economy he's trying to pump your
inflation to blame it on his political
enemy
and all the while if republicans get
control they're going to raise your
taxes to try to get back that nine
billion dollars that greg abbott cost
you right
but
you know
it is way more important that cnn plus
is is is is in the [ __ ] i mean
breaking
cnn plus right well i mean that's why we
go through the tweety tweets and
attorney trends here on the show and
this is why it's so important for people
understand when i'm going through this
stuff it isn't just because i want to
you know rant and rave but i want to
show you i want to show you what our
political discourse is i want to show
you the messaging
listen i want i want all
people with means testing i think it has
to be done with me and say i don't think
we give rich which rich folks free
college free college but i i think i
think canceling student debt
ain't a [ __ ] in this country
going to go vote for democrats and save
our democracy because they want to
cancel some student debt that's all
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] but here's the thing if you
don't go participate in our democracy
you think do you think gabe that they're
gonna cancel that republicans will
cancel student debt
never [ __ ] no there won't even be
university and institutions even have
student debt for no one's gonna here's
the thing no one's gonna cancel student
well
look i think a majority of uh
of of people within the republican party
but also others have their hands in some
pots i'm not saying that they all do but
i'm saying that some of them do in
regards to
private institutions banking
institutions uh loan
loan uh institutions where this money
goes out to uh to students right they
make money on the interest rate that
they charge people that end them in debt
that you know they have to work
themselves out of for their whole life
potentially right
and
you'll have uh lawmakers who are like oh
no no we we can't do that that's too
crazy but it's only crazy because they
won't get the money anymore right well
here's a rub
if you let republicans in charge they're
banning math in florida right do you do
you think you're going to have a
situation where you you have uh children
school-age children starting school at
three instead of five do you think
you're going to have even high school at
this point they're wanting to marry 13
and 14 year olds you think they want
them to go to high school no no in
tennessee they want to marry and
missouri they want to marry 13 14 year
old girls they do not want those girls
to go to high school you think they're
not coming for the women's vote you
think we're gonna have college in the
universities no
[ __ ] no you're not they're coming for
them they hate them oh they're liberal
propaganda machines and indoctrination
camps and all this nonsense all this q
and on [ __ ] we're not making any of
this up this is all stuff despite the
fact that evidence rejects evidence in
legislation that they're trying to test
it's like god forbid somebody has to
solve for the inequality on a math
equation and then they go oh crt and
it's like that has
nothing to do
with racism or crt or anything but
that's that's they don't give a [ __ ]
about that what they care about is
people not being educated in a way that
would make them think liberally and i
don't mean like liberal like democrat or
libtard
liberally i mean i mean thinking outside
the box thinking that there's more than
just my white dumb ass right like
there's more to experience out there
right and our and when we have a small l
liberal democracy
and these people are completely
threatened by that word because they do
not know what the small l liberal means
right
they literally are coming after
everything because they're fascist and
if you think if you think voting for
republicans because democrats won't say
cancel student debt instead they're
saying things like hey
greg abbott cost us nine billion dollars
and if you let the republicans in charge
they're going to tax you to get it back
because there's a republican tax plan
that is going to tax the middle class 4
500 more per year exactly that's what
the republicans want to do they're
coming after the middle class money yeah
and there's nothing the republican party
is fueling the uneducated
and what they are doing is they are
literally
developing the prequel
for idiocracy we are getting to that
state where no one is intelligent
anymore nobody questions uh you know our
our our politicians are you know big
bodybuilders uh our doctors are someone
who
uh give you candy instead of actual
treatment right this is the type of
stuff where
right now we are in the beginning phases
of how you end up with a movie that at
one point seems so dumb and so
just insane and unbelievable
that is now becoming a reality and you
look at idiocracy and you say oh that's
a future documentary that we saw that is
exactly what it is it does seem like
they watch way too many movies and take
them seriously right
like like star wars they're like dark
manga here the last week right oh the
dark side yeah we yeah we'll do that the
dark is cool it's like no the dark
they're the bag
they were right there
there are nine movies there are nine
movies that explain this but they're on
disney plus so they can't watch them so
you know they
are on disney plus now you can't i know
yeah that is true they're you know the
mouse the mouse has them in the house
and they are like oh we don't want it
we're just gonna block you from entering
the park and then you're like are we the
baddies
we might be the baddies you are you are
mickey mouse
in a world of [ __ ] boxes like ron
desantis right be a mickey mouse